it's been a pretty heavy duty winner for
us
it's been uh a little rough whoa you
know just staying at home and
maintaining the farm no
the kids are kind of antsy
if they're cooped up for too long we're
missing a chicken I only count 29. so
it's important to get in the mouth
having a change of pace for a little bit
we have been kind of cyclic through
these similar red meats cows and
chickens and all that so it'd be nice to
get out and kind of change up the diet a
little bit
fish provides nutrients that we can't
get from our other animals and we've
been in Alaska for a whole year now so
for the first time we are going to
Mineral Lake to go ice fishing
Moses Olivia come on come on
[Music]
oh he's on the way
all right
that's probably far enough before we
check the ice I don't want you going out
before I check the thickness I want to
make sure it's safe
we should be okay enough for us to be
scooting across
television
with everything that we've had to do
this winter we've had next to no free
time so having the opportunity to go out
and do something as a family
is just such a blessing I think I want
to stop here I think this looks fine
we're gonna check and see how deep it is
[Music]
[Applause]
did you hit water I think I did
I'm gonna check
no we're still at Ice
so the trick is to try the extension
here to see if that's any good
pull up
just a little funky
oh my gosh it's still not even touching
water
I'm wondering if we're not hitting
ground or something
silly like tarp like stuff
either that or weeds or something all
right
hole number two
and move on all right follow dad
hopefully we get lucky
[Music]